that that's that's a fun little back and
forth and randy mahomes with the hammer
peter because here's when you take your
victory lap you take it in february
which is what the chiefs did and which
is what they may be doing again but the
raiders have had something to say about
it the raiders the only team
that has beaten the kansas city chiefs
in the last calendar year and it's
actually bad news i think for the
raiders because the one thing about the
chiefs this year because they're taking
the absolute best that every opponent
has to offer every given week and it's
the super bowl for everyone they play
you have to get their full focus and
attention to get the best out of them
and i think this week i don't think you
need the victory laps and the buses to
do it i think they already had the full
focus and attention of the chiefs
because the chiefs don't want to get
swept by a division rival and they're
going to do everything they can to go
out there to las vegas and get the win
peter
mike in 36 years of covering the nfl the
one thing that i can tell you is that
the stories that are in the headlines on
tuesday wednesday thursday and friday
most of them mean absolutely totally
nothing
when the game starts
and i guarantee you this might be an
asterisky
uh i i challenge you and i challenge
everybody who watches this
to read all the stories about what is
going to be a very big game
you know monday and sunday night
and i want to see how many people
spend more than one sentence
you know with a snide aside to the
victory lap it's not going to be a
factor
it's not going to mean anything
andy reid is not going to shake hands or
fist bump or anything with john gruden
and say bleepety bleep you for taking
the victory lap just it just doesn't
happen it just doesn't really mean
anything
but you know it's fun to talk about
but i kind of agree with derek carr just
play the game
let me ask you this
because the only reason this became a
thing and i wasn't even aware it had
happened it only became a thing because
andy reid in his first press conference
of raiders week
said things that suggested he was
perturbed by it he could have shut the
door on this by saying come on we don't
care what they do in their bus why are
even you know we we don't care about
that they can take the bus wherever they
want but it became clear based on the
way he answered the questions that he
wasn't a fan of that that's not what we
do you know and and it was the reporters
who were covering it that were sending
out these tweets saying oh andy reed's
upset about the the victory lap and that
that's when it got my attention and you
know he really and you have to wonder is
there a strategy is it something that
happened in the moment i don't know
but he could have ended this before it
ever even became a thing if he just
would have said come on guys what are
you talking about who cares what they do
in their bus after they win the game
well what can it hurt him to bring his
players attention to it
really you know if it
you know probably
30 guys in his locker room laugh it off
and don't care
but
what if tyron matthew gets genuinely
ticked off by it you know what
or whoever whoever it is what if
somebody gets genuinely ticked off about
it and it causes them to say okay let's
go come on we got these guys and
whatever the motivating tool is
you know why not use it all i'm saying
is that it doesn't matter
it just i just don't think it matters
and i don't think it will play one
scintilla of a factor when the game
starts
but but peter i you're you're being
inconsistent because
it will matter if tyron matthew or four
or five other guys decided from monday
we're going to do everything we can
we're going to watch extra film we're
going to be extra careful about our
nutrition we're going to make sure we
get extra sleep that's the building
blocks to having the performance on
sunday that makes the difference and if
that happens if that happens then i will
come on the show next week and say hey i
was wrong i doubt it happens but my
point is but but there's never going to
be a trail of breadcrumbs back to that
i thought what you're saying is once
it's time to play the game all that
matters is the game
but the performances that make a
difference in the game may have had
their foundation
in how pissed off some of the guys maybe
got when andy reid brought their
attention to it i'm just trying to
harmonize
how it doesn't matter and how it
potentially does matter and i think the
only way it potentially does matter is
if it got guys who otherwise may have
been a little lackadaisical in their
preparation to buckle down and end up at
the end of the road
having a better night than they
otherwise would have had
yeah i guess my point is it might happen
and andy reid is basically if he does
make a big deal of it or even mention it
to his team or in this press conference
you know i doubt he thinks okay
here's my plan i am going to say this
and 53 guys in my locker room or even
five are going to work extra hard this
week to get ready the point i'm making
is i doubt that that happens but why not
do it because it might happen it might
lead somebody to work hard i don't know
but at the end of the day i just
i've seen too many of these things
and then on sunday when the game starts
and they play the game nobody talks
about it after the game because it
doesn't matter
what does matter is the fact that the
raiders have already beaten the kansas
city chiefs they came up with a defense
that was able to at least
hold the chiefs offense
just enough in check with only 32 points
and that's the challenge that's the game
you're not going to shut down the kansas
city chiefs you just have to come up
with a way to outscore them in recent
weeks it's been more ground and pound
for the las vegas raiders it was derek
carr cutting it loose for 347 three
touchdowns against one interception back
in week five
peter i it's funny because i i spoke to
jeff heath who had the one interception
the only interception of patrick holmes
the entire year
and he was like
he didn't want to tell me what they did
he didn't want to get too far i i asked
him for some specifics of what you did
to slow down the chiefs well we have to
play them again smart move by jeff heath
but you know the chiefs are going to
have access to the film obviously
they've been studying it they see what
the raiders tried to do
i i can't imagine
that you can that you can
shut down or at least slow down
just enough the kansas city offense
twice and there's also i think a
responsibility that kansas city defense
to not give up 40.
yeah you know i think one of the things
you're going to see in this game mike
that maybe you didn't see enough of i
think there's going to be more pressure
on derrick carr
in this game
because derek carr is more comfortable
with gruden now i think he's got a
uh he's got almost a devil may care
thought about his job in his life
because he understands how hard it is to
play quarterback for john gruden
so i think i think
the chiefs want to make
derek carr uncomfortable more
uncomfortable than he was in the first
game and on the other side
i think one of the things
that patrick mahomes has to view going
into this game is
this team has got the kind of speed that
was drafted
to stop me you know i mean everybody in
the in the afc west you look at what
denver has done in the draft you look at
what uh
what
mike mayok has done in his draft and you
basically say
that
they are drafting people to disrupt
patrick mahomes and to keep up
offensively
with
the explosive kansas city chiefs and
that's why to me be physical with henry
ruggs and put more pressure
on derek carr that to me is the formula
for the kansas city defense in this game
yeah they have to do something different
than what they did last time or it won't
matter how many points they score if
they can't slow down the raiders offense
and that raiders offense
as i mentioned we have seen far more
ground and pound recently and that seems
to be a formula that they've embraced
you know last week you had over 100
yards for josh jacobs devontae booker
had uh i think close to 90 yards rushing
derrick carr had 154 yards passing and
uh you know we saw that against
cleveland as well now that was a windy
day in cleveland when that occurred but
yeah
the best way to outscore the the chiefs
offense is to keep them off the field
and if the new formula for the raiders
is ball control
clock management
frustrate patrick mahomes make him stand
on the sideline drinking gatorade as
sims likes to say
you know we could see something that has
far fewer than 72 combined points this
time around
i i think it i think it will be a lower
scoring game um
and i also think that patrick mahomes
you know last night coming into that
game the one thing i was thinking about
russell wilson was
everybody in the world is saying well
now he's a turnover machine he's not the
mvp anymore
russell wilson i think really loves
those moments
and he absolutely loves coming out in a
game when everybody said well what color
jersey thrown into tonight russell
and
so you saw what happened last night you
know with the exception of some sloppy
penalties russell wilson played a re
regardless what the numbers said he
played a really good really efficient
smart football game and did everything
he had to do to win
in my opinion
look at the super bowl in the middle of
the fourth quarter
chiefs down by 10 points
at the time mike and and i remember
saying this after the game to andy reid
if the game was 50 minutes long my go to
the game was going to be patrick mahomes
and
he turned it around
he took it on his shoulders he said we
are not losing this game he comes to the
sidelines he said do we have time to run
wasp and eric b enemy says it to andy
and andy figures it out mike kafka is
there the quarterback coach and they all
say okay let's run two jet chip wasp
44 yards later the game has totally been
turned around with that pass to tyreek
hill uh up the left seam and so to me
i look at patrick mahomes today
thinking about this game on sunday and
and thinking that that's not going to
happen again we're going to win this
game
will it matter i think some of that
really does matter i think it matters a
heck of a lot more than what direction a
bus took uh when they left arrowhead
stadium a month or so ago
one of the other issues that's going to
matter is the covet issues the raiders
are dealing with again just like the
last time they were due to play on
sunday night football when the offensive
line was gone now the defense is grossly
undermanned this week during practice
the players most of them except for
cleveland farrell who's positive for
cover 19. all the others were close
contacts they won't be back until the
weekend the chiefs got as of last night
their two starting tackles back from the
covet 19 reserve list eric fisher and
mitchell schwartz but this is you know
to echo the point we discussed earlier
the nfl doesn't care you got to get your
guys ready and you got to go play and
it's next man up if you don't have
enough players because guys are on the
covet 19 reserve list but that
definitely is going to affect the
raiders defense come sunday night all
right earlier in the day on sunday it
will be the tennessee titans at the
baltimore ravens a rematch of the
division around playoff game from the
saturday night last year when the titans
went in and ended the 14-2 season for
baltimore here's lamar jackson the
ravens quarterback and reigning mvp on
whether he views this as a revenge game
a lot of fans feel that going against
the titans again and and what that what
happened in the playoff game uh that
this is a revenge game does that gain
factor into this game at all
uh you know that it's not a revenge game
you know um the game is over it you know
it was last year and we just fell short
can't do nothing do anything about it
you know we just going into this game
trying to be 7-3
that's all we looking into it like a
revenge game
yeah and i i never get this idea of
revenge revenge for what it'd be
different if somebody from the titans
kneecapped lamar jackson on the way to
the locker room after the game right
that's when you want revenge all the
titans did was show up and try to win a
football game
and the ravens let them win
not intentionally but there's no reason
to want revenge i know that can be a
motivator as well that can get guys
fired up that can get them to do all the
things they need to do in the week
preceding the game so they're ready to
perform at the highest possible levels
but
peter the titans just flat out kicked
their butts last year and it doesn't
matter this time around what matters
this time around is whoever loses this
is in trouble that's what matters the
titans at six and three they've lost
three of their last four after starting
5-0 the ravens now have more losses this
year than they had all of last year
whoever loses this game falls to six and
four and has to start worrying about
whether or not they're going to be in
the playoffs when we assumed both teams
would be back
one of these teams may not be especially
if it's the ravens because then they got
the steelers on thursday night
and uh
the division may already be lost the
question is can you hang on to a wild
card spot
you know i think the most worrisome
thing if i'm
if i'm john harbaugh and if i'm greg
roman quite honestly
is not necessarily
uh the inconsistency
of lamar jackson and that would worry me
but it's just the fact that the last two
weeks you know when they have been very
shaky on offense have been the worst two
weeks of the year
for the running game this is supposed to
be the best running game in football and
the last two weeks they've run for 110
and 115 yards they've averaged 3.4 yards
a carry over the last two weeks
not good enough not even close to being
good enough you're gonna have to run the
ball and run the ball successfully
against uh you know against the
tennessee titans to have a chance to win
and that comes after the 265 yards they
put up against the pittsburgh steelers
in a game that they somehow lost and
under the ravens believe that they
kicked the steelers butts
in that game but it doesn't matter the
only stat that matters is points scored
versus points allowed and you know it
was a much easier road for the steelers
in the three games between
first and second ravens game it's been
much more difficult and challenging for
the ravens
and it just feels like they're limping
into these two critical games sunday
against the titans
thursday against the steelers i mean
they could be
seven and five
by the time we get to next friday which
is and that's the one thing that is both
fascinating and potentially depressing
about short week football
from a sunday morning
by friday you could pick up two wins you
could pick up two losses and this time
of year you pick up two losses
you may be cooked if you're the ravens
and so this is a sneaky huge huge game
because it's going to resonate beyond
this sunday and if the titans should
lose it if they can't rediscover what
they were doing right earlier this year
and i don't understand why they've
gotten away from giving the ball to
derek henry as much as they did ryan
tannehill was explaining it earlier this
week about why they've deliberately
reduced his touches well they were 5-0
when he was getting all the touches
they're one in three since they have
begun to consciously limit
the opportunities for derrick henry i
mean look at that the total yards per
game down more than a hundred peter the
passing yards down dramatically the
points per game down more than 10
they need to get this figured out a team
that looked like a juggernaut not that
long ago is now one of these teams where
you're like hey you know what you may
not make the playoffs either
i think it all starts with you know
before the season losing the right
tackle jack conklin in free agency to
cleveland and now losing the left tackle
taylor lawn in the middle of this big
slump
uh and so now you're playing
basically you're back up tackles
at each tackle spot and you're asking
the offense to be as efficient
or more
as it was when you had two
standard bearers at tackle you don't
have that anymore and so it's just like
what the dallas cowboys found out when
you take away
three or four of your great offensive
linemen and you throw guys out there
ezekiel elliott's going to average 3.8
yards a carry now you know there's a lot
about ezekiel elliott's game this year i
don't like but clearly he's at a huge
disadvantage without that line and i
believe that ryan tannehill is at a
disadvantage with the line being
lessened in quality and look
a month ago or so we were all talking
about i know i was at the front of the
line ryan tannehill this is who he is
this is the real ryan tannehill over the
last 16 games he's the leading
quarterback and passer rating yards per
carry yards per attempt all that
but
now we're seeing what happens when he
doesn't have his full
uh compliment of skill players up front
and i'm calling those two tackles skill
players because for them their quickness
and lateral movement really were that of
skilled players
i mean this is just one of the realities
of football that drives a lot of people
crazy when a team is firing on all
cylinders offensively
the people who are getting the
statistics are the ones who get the
praise we never stop to say hey
that great game by derek henry was
brought to you by great blocking up
front we he praise on the guy that
actually runs the football and then when
we flip it around all of a sudden he's
not playing well well the offensive line
stinks well let's remember that the next
time the offensive line is playing
really well and give those guys more
credit for allowing great players to do
great things while they continue to toil
in anonymity great game coming in the
late afternoon window you know cowboys
vikings was the marquee match-up back in
april for week 11 at 4 25 pm eastern now
not
it's packers colts slid into that time
spot by the nfl a couple of weeks ago a
great decision by the powers that be
because the packers at seven and two the
colts at six and three this is a great
you know this is one of those it feels
like it should happen more than once
every four years right to your idea that
when they add the 17th game maybe
packers colts should happen more than
once every four years and i like the
idea of aaron rodgers and company going
to indianapolis with a colts team that
continues to be i think a little
underrated i look at them as up and down
and look at their six and three and they
were pretty good last thursday night and
you know they can hold their own with
that defense against the green bay
packers and we've seen the packers
struggle to develop energy especially at
home with no one in the stands well
there'll be people in the stands
on sunday in indianapolis and i don't
know if that gets them to perform a
little more efficiently and effectively
right out of the gates but this is not
going to be an easy one for the packers
this is not check the w and move on the
colts know what's in front of them they
know the opportunity they have with the
titans slumping a bit
and this is a chance for the colts to
really grab everyone's attention that
they are a team that needs to be taken
seriously
this reminds me of the old game when the
uh
you know we've talked about this before
you know when the giants played the
bills in the super bowl in 1990
and uh the giants
uh had a radical upset of the 49ers
kicked five field goals to make it to
that super bowl against buffalo buffalo
blew out oakland 51-3
uh
you know in the afc championship game
and right after the game bill parcells
the giants coach looked at ron earhart
his offensive coordinator and said
shorten the game
you know play clock ball in other words
keep the ball out of jim kelly's hands
and mike you know what the more things
change the more they stay the same 30
years later
if i am
uh matt lafleur
i am being very very cautious this week
in telling my team
take advantage of your chances
might only get eight possessions maybe
nine because i think the way the colts
are going to play this game
you've seen nahim heinz come out of
nowhere i think fourth round pick in
2018
uh
and and and now more
than you more than you could have
imagined with philip rivers as the
quarterback
it's the running game you know with
nahim heinz and jonathan taylor
particularly basically those are the
guys who in my opinion are going to tell
the tale of this game for the
indianapolis colts if they have 30
rushes
on sunday at the end of this game i will
have said or i'll say that
the colts will win this game because
that'll mean
they would have one time of possession
say 33 35
rushes they would have won time of
possession and kept the ball out of
aaron rodgers hands
boy there was a time not that long ago
where jim irsay the owner of the colts
was touting marlon mack as the next
great running back in the nfl he had
that rupture to kill his tendon back in
week one and they've got the revolving
door going between heinz and taylor and
jordan wilkins and i
that that when you talk about contracts
for running backs and just balancing
that that it's very delicate if you have
that star running back
the fans fall in love with him
and you can't let him go when you spread
it around you can just you can let one
go and then the next one that your draft
comes in and it just makes so much more
sense if you can make it work they're
making it work in indianapolis where
you've got three guys who share the load
they don't seem to be selfish i tried to
ask nahim heinz about that last week i
got the impression these guys are fine
with each other there isn't that
greediness that would creep into it they
take the opportunities they can get and
they make the most out of them but
you're right peter if the if the colts
can slow the game down frustrate aaron
rodgers make him press a little bit more
when he is on the field and that defense
is very good and you know we get back to
where's the help for aaron rodgers now
may have alan lazard back this week
marquez valdez scantling did very well
last week with 149 yards and a long
touchdown against jacksonville you know
i i wonder how much of that near miss
against jacksonville operates as a kick
in the ass to the packers
which is which is a big you know they're
holding on to the one seed and that one
seed can go away very quickly they don't
have to worry about anyone really
breathing down their necks in the
division but they do have to worry about
getting the bye week versus not getting
the bye week and that should be all the
reason that they need to try to handle
the cults and and just remind everyone
hey there you know nfc west you guys can
fight with each other about who the
champion is and saints bucks have fun
we'll see at lambeau field come mid
january
you know the other thing mike is
you know
i think that
darius leonard
and his friends on that on that
indianapolis defense guys like denicko
autry who are terminally
underappreciated
those guys on that defense are basically
saying
this is
this is a huge game for us we're going
to be on national tv we're going to show
america that we're not just yeah you
look at their stats their stats are
wonderful six of their nine games
they've held teams under 300 yards so
that's fantastic
but
they don't really have the appreciation
nationwide that they should as a defense
they come in on sunday and if darius
leonard and matt eberflus the defensive
coordinator
if they're hitting the right notes this
week as they prepare for this game
they're saying this is our chance
to show everybody that we're not just
going to
win games and be anonymous let's make a
name for ourselves this week
yeah and look the offseason acquisition
of deforest buckner they gave up a first
round pick happily to get him and pay
him that has helped solidify the
interior defensive line and then xavier
rhodes who they grabbed off the scrap
heap he knows aaron rodgers really well
now rogers knows him well to me that's
an intriguing matchup that's a little
chess match who will he cover he has had
a career rebirth in indianapolis and he
may remember a few things about rogers
rogers may remember a few things about
him that that boy that ah
i almost wish this game was in prime
time so we could just focus on that and
nothing else
that's how big of a game i think this is
and how significant it's going to be to
the playoff field peter in each
conference and really if the colts can
pull this one off then everyone is on
notice they can't claim
that they are overlooked and disregarded
and
they welcomed the titans to town
next week to deliver the potential death
blow to tennessee
it's it's uh
you know the end of this season has so
many interesting parts
of the schedule you know we talked
earlier about how you know the arizona
cardinals now in the span of 15 days
have to go to foxboro and east
rutherford and you know you talk about
the indianapolis colts and you're
absolutely right in the span of eight
days
that you know they've got two monster
games
they got aaron rodgers and then they got
the tennessee titans you know for the
second time in a couple of weeks so to
me this is
there's a reason why howard katz
gets a lot of love from
people around the league and i think
it's because he and his scheduling team
you know mike north and and the other
guys on that team
do such a really good job in trying to
figure out through the course of the
season and they're figuring out in april
mike
but they figure out in the course of the
season
when do we want games to be played and
how do we want to stack them and you
know they're already thinking about some
of the games
you know later in the season that might
have to be flexed so
and and i don't think there will be more
than one maybe two of those but and then
in the last week of the season some
fantastic potential matchups in week 17
to put on nbc on on sunday night
assuming of course that there isn't a
week 18
and that of course would throw
everything up in the air again
all i want for christmas is for all the
games to be played here's hoping that
the nfl can keep rocketing toward these
great games to come as the season
reaches hopefully a crescendo on week 17
with no week 18 ideally
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports